imagine creating an account on a new
website
you provide your email address and set a
password that you are confident
and you would not forget what about the
website owner
how securely are they going to store
your password
for website administrators they have
three alternatives
they can either store the passwords in a
plain text format
they can encrypt the passwords using an
encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value
let's have a look at each of these when
a password is stored in clean text
format
it is considered to be the most unsafe
option since
anyone in the company can read your
passwords a single hack and a data
server breach
will expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra effort
to counter this owners can encrypt the
passwords and keep them in the servers
as a second alternative but that would
mean they also have to store the
decryption key somewhere on their
servers
in the event of a data breach or the
server hack both the decryption key and
encrypted passwords will be leaked
thus making it a single point of failure
what if there was an option to store the
passwords after scrambling them
completely
but with no way to decrypt them this is
where hashing comes to play
since only the hashed values are stored
in the server
though encryption is needed with no
plain text passwords to protect
your credentials are safe from the
website administrators
considering all the pros cached
passwords are the industry standard when
it comes to storing credentials nowadays
hey everyone this is bible from simply
learn welcome to this video on what is
hashing
let's see the topics that we need to
cover today we understand what is
hashing
and the base concept behind its
implementation we move on to hash
functions
and then take a look at the guidelines
that need to be followed when setting
the algorithm among other things
in the end we take a look into how we
can further strengthen hash values
and make them more resistant to being
cracked
before getting too deep into the topic
let's get a brief
overview of how hashing works
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of information or data beyond
recognition
we can achieve this by using hash
functions which are essentially
algorithms that perform mathematical
operations on the main plain text
the value generated after passing the
plaintext information through the hash
function
is called the hash value digest or in
general just the hash of the original
data
while this may sound similar to
encryption the major difference is
hashes are meant to be irreversible
no decryption key can convert or digest
back to its original value
however a few hashing algorithms have
been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity
of today's new generation computers and
processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in news among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification
etc like we discussed earlier
websites use hashing to store the user's
passwords
so how do they make use of these hash
passwords
when a user signs up to create a new
account the password is then run through
the hash function
and the resulting hash value is stored
on the servers
so the next time a user comes to login
to the account
the password he enters is passed through
the same hash function
and compared to the hash stored on the
main server
if the newly calculated hash is the same
as the one stored on the website server
the password must have been correct
because according to hash functions
terminology
same inputs will always provide the same
outputs
if the hashes do not match then the
password entered during login
is not the same as the password entered
during the sign up
hence the login will be denied this way
no plain text passwords get stored
preventing both the owner from snooping
on user data
and protecting users privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack
apart from password storage hashing can
also be used to perform
integrity checks when a file is uploaded
on the internet
the files hash value is generated and it
is uploaded
along with the original information when
a new user downloads the file he can
calculate the digest of the downloaded
file using the same hash function
when the hash values are compared if
they match
then file integrity has been maintained
and there has been no data corruption
since so much important information is
being passed on to the hash function
we need to understand how they work
a hash function is a set of mathematical
calculations
operated on two blocks of data the main
input is broken down into two blocks of
similar size
the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being used
hash functions are designed to be one
way they shouldn't be reversible
at least by design some algorithms like
the previously mentioned md5 have been
compromised
but most secure algorithms are being
used today like the sha family of
algorithms
the digest size is also dependent on the
respective algorithm being used
md5 has a digest of 128 bits while she
256 has a digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input
irrespective of how many times the
calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check
if the data is untouched as the
functions are not reversible
there are certain requirements of a hash
function that need to be met
before they are accepted while some of
them are easy to guess
others are placed in order to preserve
security in the long run
the hash function must be quick enough
to encrypt large amounts of data at a
relatively fast pace
but it also shouldn't be very fast
running the algorithm on all cylinders
makes the functions easy to boot force
and a security liability
there must be a balance to allow the
hash function to handle large amounts of
data
and not make it ridiculously easy to
brute force by running through all the
possible combinations
the hash function must be dependent on
each bit of the input
the input can be text audio video or any
other file extension
if a single character is being changed
it doesn't matter how small that
character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value
this is essential to create unique
digest for every password that is being
stored
but what if two different users are
using the same password
since the hash function is the same for
all users both the digest will be the
same
this is called a hash collision you may
think this must be a rare occasion
where two users have exactly the same
password but that is not the case
we have techniques like salting that can
be used to reduce these hash collisions
as we will discuss later in this video
you would be shocked to see the most
used passwords of 2020.
all of these passwords are laughably
insecure and since many people use the
same passwords repeatedly on different
websites
cash collisions risks are more common
than one would expect
let's say the hash functions find two
users having the same password
how can they store both the hashes
without messing up the original data
this is where salting and peppering come
to play
salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
for each user on the system
and it is called the salt value or just
the sort
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the salt value will differ
and so will they digest there is a small
problem with this process though since
the salt is unique for each user
they need to be stored in the database
along with the passwords and sometimes
even in plain text to speed up the
process of continuous verification
if the server is hacked then the hashes
will need to be brute forced
which takes a lot of time but if they
receive the salts as well
the entire process becomes very fast
this is something that peppering aims to
solve
peppering is the process of adding a
random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string
is not unique for each user it is
supposed to be common for
all users in the database and the extra
bit added is called the pepper
in this case the pepper isn't stored on
the servers
it is mostly hard coded onto the website
source code
since it's going to be the same for all
credentials this way
even if the servers get hacked they will
not have the right paper needed
to crack into all the passwords many
websites use a combination of salting
and preparing
to solve the problem of hash collision
and bolster security
since brute force takes such a long time
many hackers avoid taking the effort
the returns are mostly not worth it and
the possible combinations of using both
salting and peppery is humongous hope
you learned something interesting today
feel free to ask us in the comments
section if you have any questions
and subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here